♪ ♪
>> Katie: THE CALIFORNIA
CRACKED CRACKDOWN ON CRIMINAL
IMMIGRANTS.
BROWN, A DEMOCRAT, OVER THE
WEEKEND, PARDONED A PAIR OF
IMMIGRANTS CONVICTED OF FELONIES
TO TRY TO SAVE THEM FROM
DEPORTATION.
ONE OF THEM GUILTY OF A
GANG-RELATED WEAPONS CHARGE.
CAN PRESIDENT TRUMP STOP THE
GOLDEN STATE FROM BECOMING A
SANCTUARY STATE FOR SUCH FELONS?
JOINING US NOW FOR DEBATE FROM
SAN DIEGO IS JOHN COX, A
AND IN FORT WORTH, TEXAS,
FRANCISCO HERNANDEZ, AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
SO FRANCISCO I WANT TO START
WITH YOU TO LAY THE LEGAL GROUND
HERE.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW A PARDON
FROM A STATE GOVERNOR FOR STATE
CRIMES SHIELDS AND EMIGRANTS
WITH A FELONY FROM DEPORTATION,
WHICH IS A FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> WELL, BECAUSE HE PARDONED THE
UNDERLYING OFFENSES, WHICH IS
YOSEMITE SAM IN ARIZONA.
YOU CAN'T PARDON SOMEBODY WHO
DIDN'T ADMIT THEY HAVE DONE
SOMETHING WRONG.
BUT BOTTOM LINE, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
WE'VE GOT THE RESOLVE THIS ISSUE
IF WE ARE TALKING THE
OFFENSE --
>> Katie: SPECIFICALLY TO THE
PHONE DON'T KNOW MIKE FELONY.
PEOPLE REALLY HAVE QUESTIONS
CRIMES.
THAT IS SOMETHING GOVERNORS DO
ALL THE TIME.
BUT HOW DOES THAT SHIELD
SOMEBODY FROM A DEPORTATION?
>> IT MAY OR MAY NOT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Katie: IT DOES MATTER.
>> PASSING THE STATE LAWS --
>> Katie: WE ARE GOING TO GO
FOR JOHN COX.
YOU ARE RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT MATTERS, KATIE, AS YOU SAID
BECAUSE THE FIRST JOB OF ANY
GOVERNOR IS TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE, AND WHAT JERRY BROWN
CONTINUES TO DO, MISMANAGING THE
STATE, AND EXPOSE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MORE DANGER.
YOU KNOW, THE RULE OF LAW IS
SACROSANCT, KATIE.
IT'S A THING THAT PROTECT US,
IT'S THE THING THAT MAKES US
THAT WE
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'T
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'L
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'V
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'E
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'I
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'N
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'T
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'R
DON'T LIVE IN CHAOS AND WE DON'O
ROAMING THE STREETS BUT MY
PLATFORM IS TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE.
AND YOU DON'T DO THAT BY RUNNING
GAMBITS AROUND FEDERAL LAW, BY
PARDONING PEOPLE WITHOUT A
REASONABLE JUSTIFICATION.
>> Katie: FRANCISCO, QUESTION
FOR YOU -- FRANCISCO.
SHOULD THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA BE MAKING DECISIONS
FELONS BACK OUT ON THE STREET,
TO GET BACK AT DONALD TRUMP?
IS THAT REALLY THE WAY HE SHOULD
BE RUNNING THE STATE?
>> YOU ARE GIVING HIM THE
VICTORY.
HE CANNOT PARDON A FEDERAL -- IT
HE CAN PARDON -- IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
>> Katie: CAN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STILL DEPART THIS
GUY?
>> JUST BECAUSE HE PLED GUILTY,
THING HE CAN DO?
>> Katie: FRANCISCO, I WANT
YOUR LEGAL IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
I WANT YOU TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
CAN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
THROUGH IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT, STILL DEPART THIS
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
EXCUSE ME, MAY I RESPOND?
>> Katie: JOHN, GO AHEAD GO
AHEAD.
>> I AM --
>> Katie: FRANCISCO, LET JOHN
RESPOND.
JOHN, GO AHEAD.
>> EXCUSE ME, THANK YOU, KATIE.
I'M A BUSINESSMAN, KATIE.
I'VE GOT TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND
I'VE ALSO GOT TO MAKE SURE THE
RULES ARE ENFORCED.
WHAT GOVERNOR BROWN IS DOING
THIS KIND OF ACTION IS SENDING A
MESSAGE TO PEOPLE, FRANKLY,
AREN'T BEING PARDON, AS WELL.
YOU KNOW, HE IS SENDING A
MESSAGE THAT THE RULE OF LAW
DOESN'T MATTER.
AND THE THING THAT SEPARATES US
FROM A LOT OF COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD, KATIE, THAT ARE IN
CHAOS, THAT ARE NOT SUCCESSFUL,
IS THAT IN THIS COUNTRY, WE
UNPRODUCTIVE.
I AM A BUSINESSMAN, I SOLVE
PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
PROTECTION OF OUR CITIZENS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT AS
LONG AS WE HAVE POLITICIANS COME
ACROSS POLITICIANS LIKE JERRY
BROWN AND FRANKLY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM --
>> Katie: BACK TO YOU,
FRANCISCO.
HOW IS IT THAT STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND CITIES, SANCTUARY
CITIES, ARE STILL GETTING AWAY
WITH --
>> THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
SANCTUARY CITIES --
>> Katie: YES, THERE IS.
SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA JUST
IS TRYING TO BE A SANCTUARY
STATE.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
TAKE THESE FOLKS WRITE BACK
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE SO INTENT --
>> YOU SHOULD TELL -- FRANCISCO,
YOU SHOULD TELL THAT TO THE
FAMILY OF A YOUNG WOMAN WHO WAS
MURDERED IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE AUTHORITIES THERE
DID NOT INFORM THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN THEY RELEASED A
GUY FROM PRISON, FROM CUSTODY --
FRANCISCO ANOTHER QUESTION.
WE ALL KNOW ABOUT THAT CASE, WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ONTO ANOTHER
TOPIC.
FRANCISCO, IS THIS A GOOD USE OF
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT, TO BE USING PARDONS
TO PARDON IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
FELONY RECORDS?
>> THE PARDON DOES NOT MATTER.
LET'S GET ON --
>> Katie: BUT DETAILWISE, WHY
DOES IT NOT MATTER?
>> I AM HERE FOR THE 11 MILLION
PEOPLE WHO COMMITTED LEGAL
OFFENSES --
>> Katie: WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
IMMIGRANTS YESTERDAY WHO WERE
PARDONED BY JERRY BROWN --
MAYBE NOT.
THEY ARE BEING PROTECTED BY A
STATE THAT WON'T TURN THEM OVER
TO I.C.E.
>> WE ARE LETTING THE TAIL WAG
OVER TO YOU, JOHN.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU NEED TO
RESPOND.
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RULE OF LAW IS ENFORCED.
WE HAVE GOT TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
EVERYBODY THAT THE RULE OF LAW
IS GOING TO BE ENFORCED.
IF I AM ELECTED GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA, IT WILL BE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE FIRST
RULE -- AND THAT'S THE FIRST
ROLE OF A GOVERNOR, TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE.
AND JERRY BROWN IS LEADING THE
PEOPLE --
>> Katie: FRANCISCO, QUICK
>> PUBLIC SAFETY.
>> Katie: QUICK WESTWARD TO
YOU, FRANCISCO.
>> OF MY GOODNESS.
YOU ARE RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR,
YEAH, STAND FOR THE RULE OF LAW.
DON'T TAKE ON IMMIGRATION
ISSUES, FEDERAL ISSUES, THAT
YOU'VE GOT NOTHING TO DO WITH.
>> I'M NOT.
AND JERRY BROWN IS INSERTING
HIMSELF BY USING THE PARDON
POWER.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
HE IS INSERTING HIMSELF IN THE
SITUATION A SITUATION.
>> Katie: SO WE KNOW THAT THE
THEY HAD CRIMINAL RECORDS, THEY
DID THEIR TIME AND NOW FRANCISCO
SAYS THEY CAN STILL BE DEPORTED